[Music]
on this saturday night we have liftoff
james webb begins a voyage back to the
birth of the universe nasa's new
landmark mission to unearth the secrets
of the universe boldly going where no
telescope has gone before
a massacre in military-controlled
myanmar the murderous attack blamed on
government forces
covet christmas in canada where testing
for the virus doesn't take a day off for
festivities it was lined up all the way
around the corner there
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening and merry christmas more
than 30 years and 10 billion dollars
later the world's largest and most
powerful space telescope is in orbit
tonight nasa's james webb space
telescope represents a new era in space
discovery and canada is playing a
pivotal part eric sorenson explains how
it could revolutionize astronomy and
help us better understand the birth of
the universe
decollage liftoff from a tropical
rainforest to the edge of time itself
as the james webb space telescope
climbed into the sky scientists were as
nervous and excited as any child on
christmas morning so far so good
everything is nominal as each rocket
stage fell away webb was set loose
separation web space telescope go web
cheers went up and images of the earth
receded as the most powerful space
telescope ever built began a voyage in
search of the birth of the universe
they're a beginning
of one of the most amazing missions that
humanity has conceived
webb will replace the hubble telescope
that revealed stars and galaxies never
seen before but there is more to be
discovered for the last 31 years the
hubble telescope has orbited just
overhead about 550 kilometers above the
earth
the webb telescope is being sent to a
point four times further away than the
moon the trek will take about a month
and it will end up 1.5 million
kilometers away and there's a reason for
that webb requires utter darkness and
super cold conditions a solar shield the
size of a tennis court will unfold to
block the heat of the sun and the light
from the sun the earth and even the moon
the web's mirrors expanding to six and a
half meters across will capture infrared
light emitted eons ago by the first
stars it literally is going to be
opening up you know secrets from the
earliest moments of the universe there's
really not going to be any area of
astronomy that webb will not contribute
significantly to we will get closer to
the big bang 13.8 billion years ago that
set off the early formation of the
universe creating the first galaxies and
eventually our solar system and the
earth just four and a half billion years
ago
the webb telescope will look deeper into
space than ever before effectively
taking us back to see the light from the
first stars and even the darkness before
that
canada is a major partner in what is the
largest space science project in the
60-year history of the canadian space
program we're playing a big role in the
world stage canadian excellence has
helped make this flagship telescope a
reality
canadian technology will pinpoint
distant galaxies and our scientists will
be on the front lines of new discoveries
at least half of the people in canada
who got time to use the james webb space
telescope are fairly young and early in
their career and so i think this project
a a very bright future for astronomy in
canada
the webb space telescope begins a new
era in space that will expand our
understanding of where we came from and
how we got here
eric sorensen global news toronto
in the vancouver area dreams of a white
christmas came true
crews are out and about clearing the
roads after santa delivered a rare
christmas eve snowfall and more is
falling today up to 15 centimeters in
some spots temperatures are forecast to
stay well below freezing through next
week the last time bc's lower mainland
had a white christmas was back in 2008
as the snow falls on bc covid is surging
there this week the province shattered
its daily new caseload total four days
in a row testing clinics have been
overwhelmed people even lined up today
but as kyle benning reports there are
now limits on who can get tested
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a rare white christmas in vancouver
so the area in front of a brand new
kovid 19 testing center needs to be
cleared it was
lined up all the way around the corner
there and they got everybody in and out
in a matter of 15-20 minutes the line
starting early christmas morning to get
in for a quick test and some peace of
mind because i have a wife and a child
at home and i just want to double check
make sure
got a bit of a tickle and a bit of a
headache body ache even though many we
spoke with said the weight wasn't long
today bc has reached its testing
capacity only vulnerable people and
those displaying coveted symptoms will
be pcr tested everyone else receives a
rapid test the province's top doctor
noting 20 000 tests were done on
december 23rd alone just ahead of the
holidays but this is going to be a
christmas where we have control we can
do things and part of that means
sacrificing again and supporting each
other to stay away if we're feeling sick
at all in the last week quebec ontario
and bc have all shattered daily kova 19
case counts as the omicron variant
becomes the dominant strain across the
country public health officials continue
to ask canadians to limit contacts to
avoid overloading hospitals at the
beginning of 2022
kyle benning global news vancouver
the rest of the world is also feeling
omicron tightening its grip pandemic
protocols are piling up again in many
countries but as shawn o'shea explains
it's not keeping crowds away
[Music]
at st peter's basilica in the vatican
pope francis celebrated christmas eve
mass
once again with fewer of the faithful
inside and wearing masks the pope
calling for more dialogue to prevent
global wars and to settle family feuds
while also praying for an end to the
pandemic and urging vaccine distribution
to the poor
outside in saint peter's square hundreds
stood in the rain to see francis at the
central balcony deliver a blessing i
think i'm lucky to get to see this and
especially during covid in bethlehem
christmas celebrations returned after
being cancelled last year with the
traditional marching band parade
palestinian muslims and christians
gathered in manger square they held
midnight mass of the church of the
nativity housing the grotto where jesus
was born in taiwan crowds welcomed
christmas in the rain in a manner more
common at new year's with a countdown
in england a long-standing tradition the
royal christmas message queen elizabeth
has given it every year except one since
1952. while kobeed again means we can't
celebrate quite as we may have wished
we can still enjoy the many happy
traditions and perhaps a new one the
duchess of cambridge playing piano at a
christmas concert while britons were
urged to get vaccinated over the
holidays there is still a wonderful
thing you can give
your family and the whole country
and that is
to get that jab in the hope that by next
christmas the coveted crisis may be in
the past shadow shea global news
queen elizabeth got very personal in her
annual christmas message this year
honoring who she described as her
strength and stay the late prince philip
her husband of 73 years
his sense of service
intellectual curiosity
and capacity to squeeze fun out of any
situation
were all irrepressible
that mischievous inquiring twinkle was
as bright at the end as when i first set
eyes on him
but life of course consists of final
partings as well as first meetings
and as much as i and my family miss him
i know he would want us to enjoy
christmas
prince philip died in april at the age
of 99. the 95 year old queen also said
she's looking forward to her platinum
jubilee next year marking her 70 years
of service
some sad news tonight canadian comedian
candy palmiter has died social media
reports she died suddenly today at the
age of 53 no cause of death has been
released she was a writer broadcaster
member of the migma nation and was the
president of the dalhousie aboriginal
law students association
a christmas eve massacre in myanmar
coming up what at least one human rights
group calls a crime against humanity
[Music]
a gruesome story is emerging out of
myanmar tonight reports say the
country's military rulers shot and
killed more than 30 people then torched
the bodies photos show a truck burning
with
a gruesome story is emerging out of
myanmar tonight reports say the
country's military rulers shot and
killed more than 30 people then torched
the bodies photos show a truck burning
with plumes of black smoke in the air
the victims are said to include women
children and the elderly all trying to
escape fighting in the region according
to state media government troops called
the victims terrorists with weapons from
the opposition armed forces the military
seized control of myanmar in february
next a global national tradition our
salute to our staff
and tonight's your canada is montreal
we'll be right back
[Music]
time for a global national tradition our
tribute to the small but mighty villages
who produce this newscast the west block
and the new reality there are a lot of
people working around the clock you
never see and sometimes their pets keep
them company
thank you for trusting us to bring you
the news on behalf of donna and everyone
here at global we want to wish you and
your families a very safe and happy
christmas make the most of what you can
during these tough times i'm colleen
christie i'll see you right here
tomorrow good night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
i said i wasn't gonna cry
you guys you really did this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]